so folks Michelle Obama has been going
on with her let's move campaign where
she wants a fitter healthier America so
my guess is she's going to help people
stop smoking help men with her body mass
index and women with their problem thigh
areas but no she's just doing things
like lobbying Olive Garden to remove
french fries from the kids menu that's
one way to do it
firstly I don't believe that obesity is
an epidemic in the United States okay so
you're saying we have a problem of too
much food we have a problem of too much
overabundance of too much choice so some
people choose to be fatty Macpherson's
well guess what you try explaining that
problem some Zambian famine victim watch
them get their head around it okay but I
think that we all should want a better
healthier happier America so on that
Michelle Obama and I agree but I don't
want to see this being used for
political football or millions of
dollars being involved so here you go
America I am going to save you a whole
bunch of money millions possibly
billions possibly trillions we keep
upping the ante here with everything of
dollars I'm going to let you in on the
secret that will lead to all of you
living a healthier happier more fit more
fulfilling life two big secrets here
America eat less move more
if you're still here that means you're
probably asking the question what kind
of moving should I be doing unless in
folks on this channel I genuinely do
want to help people that's why I'm doing
this video okay I don't want to just
criticize people and not offer solutions
and if there are some people out there
who genuinely do want to get fit and
healthy and in 2011 don't know how well
you probably not have the internet so
you're probably not watching this
anyways but if you are by some chance if
you're at a friend's house I want to
help you okay so firstly most important
you need to be lifting weights it's the
Fountain of Youth
it'll keep you strong it'll keep you
flexible it'll keep you mobile it'll
prevent osteoporosis everything good on
earth comes from lifting weights it's
just a fact the scientific fact how
should you be doing it heavy compound
lifts what do I mean by that compound
means multi-joint lifts you don't want
to be that guy who goes to the gym and
his spandex shorts and his grunting
trying to lift 15 pounds in a little
pink dumbbell so we can pump up his guns
okay that doesn't benefit anybody
certainly not you and definitely not
anybody else in the gym
you need to be doing weight that's heavy
for you weight mean it is difficult for
you but you can get out in a series of a
few repetitions and you can incremental
e increase you can measure your progress
the lifts you should be doing whatever
workout you do should revolve around
these lifts okay number one the squat
very important does everything great for
your your legs your butt your back your
neck your shoulders your core everything
is working this lift deadlifts are
really important another full-body lips
that is more pulling than pushing as
opposed to the squat overhead press this
is the single most important upper body
lift you're standing and you're throwing
a weight overhead it doesn't get more
basic primitive or functional than that
pull-ups these are great you can do them
anywhere if you have problems doing
pull-ups you can just jump up and pull
yourself up to the bar lower yourself as
slowly as you can and start working up
to it
bench press or dips some kind of
horizontal pressing movement and finally
rows if you create a workout plan for
yourself based around these lifts if you
only did these lifts you'll be fit
you'll be strong you'll be healthy there
are people out there gym Wendler Mike
mauler
people at elite fitness would recommend
reading they provide tremendous
information and should go out and read
it now aside from that for your cardio
you should be doing conditioning
anything you like to do it's really
basic make it fun for yourself if you
like tennis play tennis if you like
swimming swimming if you like doing the
pole dancing thing I hear that's a
fitness class or even doing it in some
churches now I'm not here to judge you
go ahead and you do that let's get to
diet ok diet pretty simple right here ok
I'm not going to start going into your
hormone levels and measuring your your
thetan levels like Tom Cruise in the
back of a Scientology Church what you
need to do here is eat a balanced meal
and monitor your calories if you want to
lose weight eat less you want to gain
weight eat more if you want to lose
weight also cut back your carbs a little
bit especially in the evening or
afternoon that's really about all you
need to know when it comes to diet of
course do more research find what works
for you but if you do all of this you
will be healthy you will be happier
more fit and a little more fulfilling
life so congratulations America I just
saved you hundreds of millions of
dollars